hello and welcome to scikit-learn
tutorial part 1 my name is Richard
Kirchner with the simply learned team
that's w w simply learned comm get
certified get ahead now we're gonna
cover the scikit-learn tutorial which
has a lot of features and all kinds of
api in it to explore data and do your
data science with effects it's probably
one of the top data science packages out
there so what is the site can't learn
it's simple and efficient tool for data
mining and data analysis it's built on
numpy side pie and mat plot library so
it interfaces very well with these other
modules and it's an open source
commercially usable bsd license bsd are
really stood for berkeley software
distribution license but it means it's
open source with very few restrictions
as far as what you can do with it
another reason to really like the
scikit-learn set up so you don't have to
pay for it as a commercial license
versus many other copyrighted platforms
out there what we could achieve using
the scikit-learn we use class the two
main things or classification and
regression models classification
identifying which category and object
belongs to for one application very
commonly used is spam detection so is it
a spam or is it not a spam yes/no in
banking you might be is this a good loan
bad loan today we'll be looking at wine
is it gonna be a good wine or a bad wine
and regression is predicting an
attribute associated with an object
one example is dock prices prediction
what is gonna be the next value if this
dock today sold for twenty three dollars
and five cents a share what do you think
it's gonna sell for tomorrow and the
next day and the next day so that would
be a regression model
same thing with weather weather
forecasting any of these are regression
models we're looking at one specific
prediction i want to tribute today we
will be doing classification like i said
we're gonna be looking at whether a wine
is good or bad but certainly the
regression model which is in many cases
more useful because you're looking for
an actual value is also a little harder
to follow sometimes so classification is
a really good place to start we can also
do clustering and model selection
clustering is taking an automatic
grouping of similar objects into sets
customer segmentation is an example so
we have these customers like
this they'll probably also like this or
if you like this particular kind of
features on your objects maybe you like
these other objects so it's a referral
is a good one especially in amazon.com
or any of your shopping networks model
selection comparing validating and
choosing parameters and models now this
is actually a little bit deeper as far
as a site kit learned we're looking at
different models for predicting the
right course or the best course or
what's the best solution today like I
say we're looking at wines it's gonna be
how do you get the best wine out of this
so we can compare different models and
we'll look a little bit at that and
improve the models accuracy via
different parameters and fine tuning now
this is only part one so we're not gonna
do too much tuning on the models we're
looking at but I'll point them out as we
go to other features dimensionality
protection and pre-processing
dimensionality reduction is we were
reducing the number of random variables
to consider this increases a model
efficiency we won't touch that in
today's tutorial but be aware if you
have you know thousands of columns of
data coming in but thousands of features
some of those are going to be duplicated
or some of them you can combine to form
a new column and by reducing all those
different features into a smaller amount
you can have a you can increase the
efficiency of your model it can process
faster and in some cases you'll be less
biased because if you're weighing it on
the same feature over and over again
it's gonna be biased to that feature and
pre-processing these are both
pre-processing but pre-processing is
feature extraction and normalization so
we're gonna be transforming input data
such as text reuse with machine learning
algorithms we'll be doing a simple
scaling in this one for our
pre-processing and I'll point that out
when we get to that and we can discuss
pre-processing at that point with that
let's go ahead and roll up our sleeves
and dive in and see what we got here now
I like to use the jupiter notebook and i
use it out of the Anaconda navigator so
if you install the Anaconda navigator by
default it will come with the jupiter
notebook or you can install the jupiter
notebook by itself this code will work
in any of your Python setups I believe
I'm running an environment of
three-point-seven setup on there I'd
have to go in here environments and look
it up for the Python setup but it's one
of the three x's and we go ahead and
launch this and this will open it up in
a web browser so it's kind of nice it
keeps everything separate
and in this anaconda you can actually
have different environments different
versions of Python different modules
installed in each environment so it's a
very powerful tool if you're doing a lot
of development and Jupiter notebook is
just a wonderful visual display
certainly you can use I know spiders
another one which is installed with the
anaconda I actually use a simple notepad
plus plus when I'm doing some of my
Python script any of your IDs will work
fine jupiter notebook is ironpython
because it's designed for the interface
but it's good to be aware of these
different tools and when i launch the
jupiter notebook it'll open up like i
said a webpage in here and we'll go over
here to new and create a new python i'm
set up like i said i believe this is
python 3 7 but any other three this the
scikit-learn works with any of the three
x's there's even two seven versions so
it's been around a long time so it's
very big on the development side and
then the guys in the back guys and gals
develop they went ahead and put this
together for me and let's go ahead and
import our different packages now if
you've been reading some of our other
tutorials you'll recognize pandas as p
d-- pandas libraries pretty widely used
as a data frame setup so it's just like
columns and rows and a spreadsheet with
a lot of different features for looking
stuff up the Seabourn sits on top of mat
plot libraries this is for a graphing
will see that how quick it is to throw a
graph out there to view in the jupiter
notebook for demos and showing people
what's going on and then we're gonna use
the random forest the SVC or support
vector classifier and also the neural
network so we're going to look at this
we're actually gonna go through and look
at three different classifiers that are
most common some of the most common
classifiers let's show how those work in
the scikit-learn setup and how they're
different and then if you're gonna do
your setup on here
you'll want to go ahead and import some
metrics so the SK learned metrics on
here and we're using confusion metrics
and the classification report out of
that and then we're gonna use from the
SK learn pre-processing the standard
scaler and label encoder standard scaler
is probably the most commonly used
pre-processing there's a lot of
different pre-processing packages in the
SK learn and then model selection for
splitting our data up it's one of
many ways we can split data into
different sections and the last line
here is our percentage mat plot library
in line
some of the Seaboard and mat plot
library will go ahead and display
perfectly in line without this and some
won't
it's good to always include this when
you're in the jupiter notebook this is
jupiter notebook so if you're in ite
when you run this it will actually open
up a new window and display the graphics
that way so you only need this if you're
running it in a editor like this one
with the specifically jupiter notebook
I'm not even familiar with other editors
that are like this but I'm sure they're
out there I'm sure there's a Firefox
version or something
Jupiter notebook just happens to be the
most widely used out there and we can go
ahead and hit the Run button and this
now has saved all this underneath the
packages so my packages are now all
loaded I've run them whether you run it
on top we run it to the left and all the
packages are up there so we now have
them all available to us for our project
we're working on and I'm just gonna make
a little side note on that when you're
playing with these and you delete
something out and add something in even
if I went back and deleted this cell and
just hit the scissors up here these are
still loaded in this kernel so until I
go under kernel and restart or restart
and clear or restart and run all I'll
still have access to pandas important to
know because I've done that before I've
loaded up maybe not a module here but
I've loaded up my own code and then
changed my mind and wondering why is he
keep putting out the wrong output and
then I realize it's still loaded in the
kernel you have to restart the kernel
just a quick side note for working with
a jupiter notebook and one of the
troubleshooting things that comes up
we're gonna go and load up our data set
we're using the pandas so if you haven't
yet go look at our pandas tutorial a
simple read the csv with the separation
on here so let me go ahead and run that
and that's now loaded into the variable
wine and let's take a quick look at the
actual file I always like to look at the
actual data I'm working with in this
case we have wine quality - red I'll
just open that up I haven't in my
OpenOffice setup separated by semicolons
that's important to notice and we open
that up you'll see we have go all the
way down here it looks like 1600 lines
of data - the first one so 15 1599 lines
and we have a number of features going
across the last one is quality and
have to bet we see the quality is as
different numbers in at five six seven
it's not really I'm not sure how high of
a level it goes but I don't see anything
over a seven so it's kind of five
through seven is what I see here five
six and seven four or five six and seven
looking to see if there's any other
values in there looking through the demo
or to begin with I didn't realize the
setup on this see there's a different
quality values in there alcohol sulfates
pH density total sulfur sulfur dioxide
and so on those are other features we're
going to be looking at and since this is
a pandas we'll just do wine head and
that prints our first five roles rows of
data that's of course pandas command and
we can see that looks very similar to we
were looking at before we have
everything across here it's
automatically assigned an index on the
left
that's what pandas does if you don't
give it an index and for the column
names it has assigned the first row so
we have our first row of data pulled off
the our comma separated variable file in
this case semicolon separated and it
shows the different features going
across and we have what 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 features 12 including quality
but that's the one we want to work on
and understand and then because we're in
pandas dataframe we can also do
Wyandotte info and let's go ahead and
run that this tells us a lot about our
variables we're working with you'll see
here that there is 1599 that's what I
said from the spreadsheet so it looks
correct non-null float64 this is very
important information especially the non
null there's no null values in here that
can really trip us up in pre-processing
and there's a number of ways to process
non null values one is just to delete
that data out of there so if you have
enough data in there you might just
delete your non null values another one
is to fill that information in with like
the average or the most common values or
other such means but we're not gonna
have to worry about that but we'll look
at it another way because we can also do
wine is null and sum it up and this will
give us a similar won't tell us that
these are float values but it will give
us a summation I'm sorry go let me run
that he'll give us a summation on here
how many null values in each one so
he wanted to you know from here you
would be able to say okay this is a null
value but she doesn't tell you how many
are null values this one would clearly
tell you that you have maybe five null
values here to null values here you
might just a few had only seven null
values and all that different dating
probably just delete them out where if
ninety percent of the data was no values
you might rethink either a different
data collection setup or find a
different way to deal with the null
values we'll talk about that just a
little bit in the models too because the
models themselves have some built-in
features especially the forest model
which we're gonna look at this point we
need to make a choice and to keep it
simple we're gonna do a little
pre-processing of the data and we're
gonna create some bins and bins we're
gonna do is 2 comma 6 point 5 comma 8
what this means is that we're gonna take
those values if you remember up here let
me just scroll back up here we had our
quality and the quality who comes out
between 2 and 8 basically or 1 and 8 we
have 5 5 5 6 you can see just in the
just in the first 5 lines of variation
and quality we're gonna separate that
into just two bins of quality and so
we've decided to create two bins and we
have bad and good it's gonna be the
labels on those two bins we have a
spread of 6.5 and an exact index of ate
the exact index is because we're doing 0
to 8 on there the 6.5 we can change we
could actually make this smaller or
greater but we're only looking for the
really good wide we're not looking for
the 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 we're looking for
wines with 7 or 8 on so high quality you
know this is what I want to put on my
dinner table at night I want to taste
the good wine not the semi good wine or
mediocre wine and then this is a panda
so PD member stands for pandas pandas
cut means we're cutting out the wine
quality and we're replacing it and then
we have our bins equals bins that's the
command bins is the actual command and
then our variable bins to come at 6.58
so two different bins and our labels bad
and good and we can also do let me just
do it this way wine quality since that's
what we're working on and let's look at
unique another pandas command and we'll
run this and I get this lovely error why
did I get an error
well because I replaced wine quality and
I did this cut here which changes things
on here I'm sorry literally altered one
of the variables are saved in the memory
so we'll go up here to the kernel
restart and run all that starts it from
the very beginning and we can see here
that that fixes the air because I'm not
cutting something that's already been
cut we have our wine quality unique and
the wine quality unique is a bad or good
so we have two qualities objects bad is
less than good meaning bad is going to
be zero and goods going to be one and to
make that happen we need to actually
encode it so we'll use the label quality
equals label encoder and the label
encoder let me just go back there since
as part of SK learned that was one of
the things we import it was a label
encoder you can see that right here from
the SK learn processing import standard
scaler which we're going to use in a
minute and label encoder and that's what
tells it to use that equals zero and
good equals one and we'll go ahead and
run that and then we need to apply it to
the data and when we do that we take our
wine quality that we had before and
we're gonna set that equal to label
quality which is our encoder and let's
look at this line right here we have dot
fit transform and you'll see this in the
pre-processing these are the most common
used is fit transform and fit transform
because they're so often that you're
also transforming the data when you fit
it they just combined them into one
command and if we're just gonna take the
wine quality feed it back into there and
put that back in our wine quality setup
and run that and now what we do the wine
and the head of the first five values
and we go ahead and run this you can see
right here underneath quality zero zero
zero have to go down a little further to
look at the better wines let's see if we
have some that are ones yeah there we go
there's some ones down here let's look
at ten of them you can see all the way
down to zero or one that's our quality
and again we're looking at high quality
we're looking at the seven and the eight
or six point five and up and let's go
ahead and grab our or was it here we go
wine quality let's take a look at what
else more information about the wine
quality itself we can do a simple pandas
thing value counts I type that in there
correctly and we can see that we only
have two hundred and seventeen of our
wines which are going to be the higher
quality so two hundred seventeen
and the rest of them fall into the bad
bucket and the zero which is 1382 so
again we're just looking for the top
percentage of these the top what is that
it's probably about a little under 20%
on there so we're looking for our top
wines are seven and eight and let's use
our let's plot this on a graph
so we take a look at this and the SNS if
you remember correctly that is I'm just
back at the top
that's our Seaborn Seabourn sits on top
of mat plot library it has a lot of
added features plus all the features of
the mat plot library and it also makes
it quick and easy to put out a graph
we'll do a simple bar graph and they
actually call it count plot and then we
want to just do count plot the wine
quality just put our wine quality in
there let's go ahead and run this and
see what that looks like and nice in
line members why we did the in line so
make sure it appears in here and you can
see the blue space or the first space
represents low quality wine and our
second bar is the high quality line and
you can see they were just looking at
the top quality wine here most the wine
we want to just give it away to the
neighbors and maybe if you don't like
your neighbors may become the good
quality wine and I don't know what you
do with the bed quality wine
I guess use it for cooking there we go
but you can see here it forms a nice
little graph for us with the Seabourn on
there and you can see our setup on that
so now we've looked we've done some
pre-processing we've described our data
a little bit we have a picture of how
much of the wine what we expect it to be
high quality low quality checked out the
fact that there's none we don't have any
null values to contend with or any odd
values some of the other things you
sometimes look at these is if you have
like some values that are just way off
the chart so the measurement might be
off or miss calibrated equipment fear in
the scientific field so the next step we
want to go ahead and do is we want to go
ahead and separate our data set or
reformat our data set and we usually use
capital X and that denotes that features
we're working with and we usually use a
lowercase Y that denotes what in this
case quality what we're looking for and
we can take this we can go wine it's
gonna be our full thing of wine dropping
what are we dropping we're dropping the
quality so these are all the features -
quality make sure we have our axes
equals 1 if you left it out it would
still come out correctly just because of
the way it processes on the defaults and
then
why if we're gonna remove quality for
our X this is going to be wine and it is
just the quality that we're looking at
for Y so we put that in there and we'll
go ahead and run this so now we've
separated the features that we want to
use to predict the quality of the wine
and the quality itself the next step is
if you're going to create a data set in
a model we got to know how good our
model is so we're going to split the
data train and test splitting data and
this is one of the packages we imported
from SK learn and the actual package was
trained test split and we're gonna do XY
test size point two random State 42 and
this returns four variables and most
common you'll see is capital X train so
we're gonna train our set with capital X
test that's the data we're gonna keep on
the side to test it with why train why I
remember stands for the quality or the
answer we're looking for
so when we train it we're gonna use X
train and why train and then Y test to
see how good our X test does and the
train test split let me just go back up
to the top that was part of the SK learn
model selection import train test split
there is a lot of ways to split data up
this is your first starting you do your
first model you probably start with the
basics on here you have one test for
training one for test our test size is
0.2 or 20% and random stage just means
we just start with a it's like a random
seed number so that's not too important
back there
we're randomly selecting which ones
we're going to use since this is the
most common way this is what we're gonna
use today there is and it's not even a
scaler and package yet so someone's
still putting it in there one of the new
things they do is they split the data
into thirds and then they'll run the
model on each of they combine each of
those thirds into two thirds for
training and one for testing and so you
actually go through all the data and you
come up with three different test
results from it which is pretty cool
that's a pretty cool way of doing it you
could actually do that with this by just
splitting this into thirds and then or
you'll have a test side one test set
third and then split the training set
also into thirds and also do that and
get three different data sets this works
fine for most projects especially when
you're starting out it works great so we
have our X
train or X test or white train in our Y
test and then we need to go ahead and do
the scaler and let's talk about this
because this is really important
some models do not need to have scaling
going on most models do and so we create
our scalar variable we'll call it SC
standard scaler and if you're correctly
we imported that here wrong with the
label encoder the standard scaler setup
so there's our scalar and this is gonna
convert the values instead of having
some values that go from zero if you
remember up here we had some values are
fifty four sixty forty fifty 902 so our
total sulphur dioxide would have these
huge values coming in to our model and
some models would look at that and
they'd become very biased to sulfur
dioxide and have the hugest impact and
then a value that had point oh seven six
point zero nine eight or chlorides would
have very little impact because it's
such a small number so we take the
scalar we kind of level the playing
field and depending on our scaler it
sets it up between zero and one a lot of
times is what it does let's go ahead and
take a look at that and we'll go ahead
and start with our X train and our X
train equals SC fit transform we talked
about that earlier that's an SK learn
set up it's going to both fit and
transform our X train into our X train
variable and if we have a neck strain we
also need to do that to our test and
this is important because you need to
note that you don't want to refit the
data we want to use the same fit we used
on the training is on the testing
otherwise you get different results and
so we'll do just hopes not fit transform
we're only going to transform the test
side of the data so here's our X test
that we want to transform and let's go
ahead and run that and just so we have
an idea let's go ahead and take and just
print out our X train oh let's do first
ten variables very similar the way you
do with the head on a data frame you can
see here our variables are now much more
uniform and they've scaled them to the
same scale so they're between certain
numbers and with the basic scaler you
can fine tune it I just let it do its
defaults on this and that's fine for
what we're doing
in most cases you don't really need to
mess with it too much it doesn't look
like it goes between like - probably - 2
- 2 or something like that that's just
looking at the Train variable I'll go
ahead and cut that one out of there so
before we actually build the models and
start discussing the SK learn models
we're gonna use we covered a lot of
ground here most of when you're working
with these models you put a lot of work
into pre prepping the data so we looked
at the data notice that it's separated
and loaded it up we went in there we
found out there's no null values it's
hard to say no nodal values we have
there's none there's none nobody I can't
say it
and of course we sum it up if you had a
lot of null values this would be really
important coming in here so is there a
null summary we looked at pre-processing
the data as far as the quality and we're
looking at the bins so this would be
something you might start playing with
maybe you don't want superfine wine you
don't want the 7 & 8 maybe you want to
split this differently so certainly you
can play with the bins and get different
values and make the bins smaller or lean
more towards the lower quality so you
then have like medium to high quality
and we went ahead and gave it labels
again this is all pandas we're doing in
here setting up with unique labels and
group names bad good bad is less and
good be so important you don't know how
many times people go through these
models and they have them reversed or
something and then they go back they're
like why is this data not looking
correct so it's important to remember
what you're doing up here and double
check it
and we used our label encoder so that
was to set that up as quality zero one
good in this case we have bad good zero
one and we just double check that to
make sure that's what came up in the
quality there we threw it into a graph
because people like to see graphs I
don't know about you but you start
looking at all these numbers and all
this text and you get down here and you
say oh yes you know here this is how
much of the wine we're gonna label as
subpar not good this is how much we're
gonna label as good and then we got down
here to finally separating out our data
so it's ready to go into the models and
the models take X and a Y in this case X
is all of our features - the one we're
looking for
and then Y is the features we're looking
for
so in this case we dropped quality and
in the Y case we added quality and then
because we need to have a training set
in a test set so we can see how good our
models do we went ahead and split the
models up X train X test y train Y test
and that's using the Train test split
which is part of the SK learn package
and we did as far as our testing size
0.2 or 20% the default is 25% so if you
leave that out it'll do default setup
and we did a random state equals 42 if
you leave that out it'll use a random
state I believe it's default one I'd
have to look that back up and then
finally we scaled the data this is so
important to scale the data going back
up to here if you have something that's
coming out as a hundred it's gonna
really outweigh something that's point O
seven one that's not in all the models
different models handle it differently
and as we look at the different models
I'll talk a little bit about that we're
gonna only look at three models today
three of the top models used for this
and see how they compare and how the
numbers come out between them so we're
gonna look at three different setups
let me change my cell here to mark down
there we go we're going to start with
the random forest classifier so the
three centers were looking at is a
random forest classifier support vector
classifier and then a neural network now
we start with the random forest
classifier because it has the least
amount of parts moving parts to
fine-tune and let's go ahead and put
this in here so we're gonna call it RFC
for random forest classifier and if you
remember we imported that so let me go
back up here to the top real quick and
we did an import of the random forest
classifier from SK learn ensembl and
then we'll all that we also let me just
point this out here's our SVM where we
imported our support vector classifier
so SVM is support vector model support
vector classifier and then we also have
our neural network and we're gonna from
there the multi layered perceptron
classifier kind of a mouthful for the P
perceptron don't worry too much about
that name is just it's a neural network
there's a lot of different options on
there in setups which was where they
came up with the perceptron but so we
have our three different models we're
going to go through one here and then
we're going to weigh them here's our
so we're gonna use a confusion metrics
also from the SK learn package to see
how good our model does with our split
so let's go back down there and take a
look at that and we have our RF s equals
random forest classifier and we have n
estimators equals 200 this is the only
value you play with with a random forest
classifier
how many forests do you need or how many
trees in the forest so how many models
are in here that makes it pretty good as
a start-up model because you're only
playing with one number and it's pretty
clear what it is and you can lower this
number or raise it usually start up with
a higher number and then bring it down
to see if it keeps the same value so you
have less you know the smaller the model
the better the fit and it's easier to
send out to somebody else if you're
going to distribute it now the random
forest classifier everything I read says
it's used for kind of a medium sized
data set so you can run it in big data
you can run it on smaller data obviously
but test in the mid-range and we'll go
ahead and take our RFC and I just copied
this from the other side dot fit X train
comma Y train so we're sending it our
features and then the quality in the
white rain what we want to predict in
there and we just do a simple fit I
remember this is SK learn so everything
is fit or transform another one is
predict which we'll do in just a second
here let's do that now predict are FC
equals and it's our RFC model predict
and what are we predicting on while we
train it with our train values so now we
need our test our X test so this has
done it this is going to do this is the
three lines of code we need to create
our random forest variable fit our
training data to it so we're programming
it to fit in this case it's got 200
different trees it's going to build and
then we're gonna predict on here let me
go ahead and just run that and we can
actually do something like all of us to
predict our F C just real quick we'll
look at the first 20 variables of it
let's go ahead and run that and in our
first 20 variables we have three wines
and make the cut and the other 17 don't
so the other 17 are bad quality and
three of them are good quality
in our predicted values and if you can
remember correctly go ahead and take
this out of here this is based on our
test so these are the first 20 values
and our test and this has as you can see
all the different features listed in
there and they've been scaled so when
you look at these are a little bit
confusing to look at and hard to read
but we have there's a minus 0 1 so this
is 0.36 minus I 1 so point 1 64 minus
0.09 or not still minus 1 so minus 0.9
all between 0 & 1 on here I think I was
confused earlier and I said 0 between 2
negative 2 but between minus 1 and 1
which is what it should be in the scale
we'll go ahead and just cut that out of
there run this we ever set up on here so
now we've run the prediction and we have
predicted values well one you could
publish them but what do we do with them
well we want to do with them as we want
to see how we're our model model perform
that's a whole reason for splitting it
between the training and testing model
and for that if you remember we imported
the classification report that was again
from the SK learn there's our confusion
matrix and classification report and the
classification report actually sits on
the confusion matrix so uses that
information and our classification
report we want to know how good our Y
test that's actual values versus our
predicted RFC so we'll go ahead and
print this report out and let's take a
look and we can see here we have a
precision out of the 0 we had about 0.9
t2 that were labeled as bad that we're
actually bad and out of precision for
the quality wines we're running about
78% so you kind of give us a overall 90%
and you can see our f1 score or support
setup on there or recall you could also
do the confusion matrix on here which
gives you a little bit more information
but for this this is gonna be good
enough for right now we're just gonna
look at how good this model was because
we want to compare the random forest
classifier with the other two models and
you know what let's go ahead and put in
the confusion matrix just so you can see
that on there with Y test and prediction
RFC so in the confusion matrix we can
see here that we had 266 correct and
seven wrong these are the miss labels
for bad
and we had a lot of missed labels for
good wine so our quality labels aren't
that good we're good at predicting bad
wine not so good at predicting whether
it's a good quality wine important to
note on there so that is our basic
random forest classifier and let me go
ahead of cell and change cell type to
markdown and run that so we have a nice
label let's look at our SVM classifier
our support vector model and this should
look familiar we have our C LF we're
going to create what's it we'll call it
just like we call this an RFC and then
we'll have our CL f dot fit and this
should be identical to up above X train
comma Y train and just like we did
before let's go ahead and do the
prediction and here is our CLF predict
and it's going to equal the CLF dot
predict and we want to go ahead and use
X underscore test and right about now
you can realize that you can create
these different models and actually just
create a loop to go through your
different models and put the data in and
that's how they designed it they
designed it to have that ability let's
go ahead and run this and then let's go
ahead and do our classification report
and I'm just going to copy this right
off of here
they say you shouldn't copy and paste
your code and the reason is is when you
go in here and edit it you unbearably
will miss something we only have two
lines I think I'm safe to do it today
let's go ahead and run this and let's
take a look how the SVM classifier came
out so up here we had a 90 percent and
down here running about an 86 percent so
it's not doing as good now remember we
randomly split the data so if I run this
a bunch of times you'll see some changes
down here so these numbers this size of
data if I read it a hundred times it
would probably be within plus or minus
three or four on here in fact if I ran
this a hundred times you'd probably see
these come out almost the same as far as
how well they do classification and then
on the confusion matrix let's take a
look at this one this had 22 by 25 this
one has 35 by 12 so it's doing not quite
as good that shows up here 71 percent
versus 78 percent and then if we're
gonna do a SVM classifier we also want
to show you one more before I do that
kind of tease you a little bit here
Before we jump into neural networks the
big save all deep learning because
everything else must be shallow learning
that's a joke let's just talk a little
bit about the SVM versus the random
forest classifier the SVM tends to work
better on smaller numbers it also works
really good a lot of times you convert
things into numbers and bins and things
like that the random forest tends to do
better with those at least that's my
brief experience with it or if you have
just a lot of raw data coming in the SVM
is usually the fastest and easiest to
apply model on there so the beats have
their own benefits you'll find they'll
again that when you run these like a
hundred times difference between these
two on a dataset like this is gonna just
go away
there's randomness involved depending on
which data we took and how they classify
them the big one is the neural networks
and this is what makes the neural
networks nice as they can do they can
look into huge amounts of data so for a
project like this you probably don't
need a neural network on this but it's
important to see how they work
differently and how they come up
differently so you can work with huge
amounts of data you can also many
respects they work really good with text
analysis
especially if it's time-sensitive more
and more you have an order of text and
they've just come out with different
ways of feeding that data end where the
series in the order of the words is
really important
same thing with starting to predict in
the stock market if you have tons of
data coming in from different sources
the neural network can really process at
in a powerful way to pull up things that
aren't seen before when I say lots of
data coming in I'm not talking about
just the high lows that you can run an
SVM on real easily
I'm talking about the data that comes in
where you have maybe you pulled off the
Twitter feeds and have word counts going
on and you've pulled off the different
news feeds of business are looking at
and the different releases when they
release the different reports so you
have all this different data coming in
and the neural network does really good
with that pictures picture processing
now is really moving heavily into the
neural network if you have a pixel - or
pixel 3 foam put out by Google it has a
neural network for doing it's kind of
goofy but you can put a little Star Wars
Androids dancing around your pictures
and things like that that's all done
with a neural network so has a lot of
different uses but it's also requires a
lot of data and is a little heavy-handed
for something like this and this should
now look familiar because we've done it
twice before we have our multi-layered
perceptron classifier we'll call it an
ml PC and it's this is what we imported
in ml PC classifier there's a lot of
settings in here the first one is the
hidden layers you have to have the
hidden layers in there we're gonna do
three layers of 11 each so that's how
many nodes or each layers it comes in
and that was based on the fact we have
11 features coming in then I went ahead
and just did three layers probably get
by with a lot less on this but I didn't
want to sit and play with it all
afternoon again this is one of those
things you play with a lot because the
more hidden layers you have the more
resources you're using you can also run
into problems with overfitting with too
many layers and you also have to run
higher iterations the max iteration we
have is set to 500 the defaults 200
because I used three layers of eleven
each which is by the way kind of a
default I use I realized that usually
you have about three layers going down
and the number of features going across
you'll see that it's pretty common for
the first classifier when you're working
in neural networks but it also means you
have to do higher iterations so we up
the iterations to 500 so that means it's
going through the day to 500
times to program those different layers
and carefully adjust them and we do have
a full tutorials you can go look up on
neural networks and understand the
neural network settings a lot more and
of course we have you're looking over
here where we had our previous model
where we fit it same thing here
MLP see fit X train Y train and then we
going to create our prediction so let's
do our predict and ml PC and it's going
to equal the ml PC and we'll just take
the same thing here predict X test let's
just put that down here predict a test
and if I run that we've now programmed
it we now have our prediction here same
as before and we'll go ahead and do the
copy print again I always be careful
with the copy paste not because you
always run the chance of missing one of
these variables so if you're doing a lot
of coding you might want to skip that
copy and paste and just type it in and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
that looks like and we came up with an
88% we're gonna compare that with the 86
from our tree or SVM classifier and our
90 from the random forest classifier and
keep in mind random forest classifiers
they do good on midsize data the SVM on
smaller amounts of data although to be
honest I don't think that's necessarily
the split between the two and these
things will actually come together if
you ran a number of times and we can see
down here the noun of good wines
mislabeled with set up on there it's on
par with our random forests so we had 20
to 25 shouldn't be a surprise it's
identical they just didn't do as good
with the bad wines labeling what's a bad
one what's not see yet because they had
two hundred sixty six and seven we had
down here 260 and 13 so mislabeled a
couple the bad wines is good wines so
we've explored three of these basic
classifiers these are probably the three
most widely used right now I might even
throw in the random tree if we open up
their website we go under supervised
learning there's a linear model we
didn't do that almost most of data
usually just start with a linear model
because it's gonna process the quickest
I'm gonna use the least amount of
resources but you can see they have
linear quadratic they have kernel Ridge
there's our support vector I'm
stochastic gradient nearest name
nearest neighbors is another common one
that's used a lot very similar to the
SVM Gaussian process cross decomposition
naive Bayes this is more of an
intellectual one that I don't see used a
lot but it's like the basis of a lot of
other things decision tree there's
another one that's used a lot ensemble
methods as much multi class of multi
label algorithms feature selection
neural networks that's the other one we
use down here and of course the forest
so you can see there's a SK learn there
are so many different options and they
just develop them over the years we
covered three of the most commonly used
ones in here and went over a little bit
over why they're different neural
network just because it's fun to work in
deep learning and not in shallow
learning yes I told you it doesn't mean
that the SVM is actually shallow so
there's a lot of it covers a lot of
things and same thing with the decision
for the random forest classifier and we
noticed that there's a number of other
different classifier options in there
these are just the three most common
ones and I'd probably throw the nearest
neighbor in there and the decision tree
which is usually part of the decision
for us depending on what the backend
you're using and since as human beings
if I was in the shareholders office I
wouldn't want to leave them with a
confusion matrix they need that
information for making decisions but we
want to give him just one particular
score and so I would go ahead and we
have our SK learn metrics we're gonna
import the accuracy score and I'm just
gonna do this on the random forests
since that was our best model and we
have our CM accuracy score and they
forgot to print it if you remember in
Jupiter notebook we can just do the last
variable we leave out there we'll print
and so our cm Accra score we get is 90%
and that matches up here we should
already see that up here in precision so
you can either quote that but a lot of
times people like to see it highlighted
at the very end this is our precision on
this model and then the final stage is
we would like to use this for future so
let's go ahead and take our wine just
remember correctly we'll do wine ahead
of 10 I'll run that remember our
original data set we've gone through so
many steps and we're going to go back to
the original data we can see here we
have our top 10 or top 10 on the list
only two of them make it as having high
enough quality wine for us to be
interested in them and then let's go
ahead and create some data here we'll
call it X new equals and
is important this data has to be we just
kind of randomly selected some data
looks an awful lot like some of the
other numbers on here which is what it
should look like and so we have our X nu
equals seven point three point five
eight and so on and then it is so
important this is where people forget
this step X nu equals SC remember SC
that was our standard scalar variable we
created if we go right back up here
before we did anything else
we created an SC we fit it and we
transformed it and then we need to do
what transform the data we're going to
feed in so we're going to go back down
here
and we're going to transform our x nu
and then we're gonna go ahead and use
the oh yeah here we go
our random forest and if you remember
all it is is our RFC predict model right
there let's go ahead and just grab that
down here and so our y nu equals here's
our our AFC predict I'm going to do our
X nu in and then it's kind of nice to
know what it actually puts out so
according to this it should print out
what our prediction is for this wine and
oh it's a bad wine okay so we didn't
pick out a good wine for our X nu and
they should be expected most of wine if
you remember correctly only a small
percentage of the wine met our quality
requirements so we can look at this and
say oh we'll have to try another wine
out which is fine by me cuz I like to
try out new wines and I certainly have a
collection of old wine bottles and very
few of the match but you can see here
we've gone through the whole process
just a quick read rehash we had our
imports we touched a lot on the SK learn
our random forests our SVM and our MLP
classifier so we had our support vector
classifier we had our random forests and
we have our neural network through the
top used classifiers in the SK learn
system and we also have our confusion
metric matrix and our classification
report which we used our standard scaler
for scaling it and our label encoder and
of course we needed to go ahead and
split our data up in our implant line
train and explore the data in here for
null values we set up our quality into
bins we took a look at the data and what
we actually have and put a nice little
plot to show her quality what we're
looking at and then we went through our
three different models and it's always
interesting as he spends so much time
getting to these models and then you
kind of go through the models and play
with them until you get the best
training on there without becoming bias
that's always a challenge is to not over
train your data to the point where
you're training it to fit the test value
and finally we went ahead and actually
used it and applied it to a new wine
which unfortunately didn't make the cut
it's gonna be the one that we drink a
glass out of and save the rest from
cooking of course that's according to
the random forests on there because we
use the best model that it came up with
that completes our part one of the SK
learn if you have questions or want
copies of the code feel free to put a
note in the YouTube video down below or
visit @ww simply learn calm they'll be
happy to answer questions you might have
feel free to go either in to our forums
at sub you learn comm or again in the
youtube video below again my name is
Richard Kirchner with these simply learn
t SW W simply learn comm get certified
get ahead thank you for joining us today
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here